I was more willing to engage lock antlers. When I was young,
I don't think people are going to change their minds anymore.
I don't want to be the carnival Barker on some freak show. People were split.
We'll find out where we go,
which way at each election in between it's going to be contentious. Uh,
at age 66. I don't want to wake up every day and fight with people about stuff.
They're not going to change their mind on anyway.
I'm Dave Rubin and this is the Rubin report reminder.
Everybody subscribed to Rubin report.com.
If you want to get all our videos early and totally ad free and more
importantly, joining me today as a stand-up comic and host of Dennis Miller,
plus one on the RT network, as well as the Dennis Miller option podcast,
Dennis Miller, I've already said your name three times.
What's up rubes. Welcome to the Rubin report. Beautiful pad here, man.
I'm trying to read, you can tell a man by his books and his chotchkies.
I see that you're a Carlin fan,
which I find in a little Steven Pinker NBA.
I think your detractors would say this indicates you're moving rightward towards
John Birch participation on the bottom.
Where do you have the map centered up that odd confluence between South America
and, uh, or the globe?
I should say South America and Africa where it's split up. And I have a theory.
It looks like they were together at one point yes, slips split apart.
And obviously the West coast of Africa with, uh, uh, ivory coast.
Liberia is the most contentious place in the planet. And I think that's a, uh,
sudden hard drive tremble from way back when,
where a guy went out into his yard in Liberia once and said, honey,
what's this crack. And then two weeks later.
I've often wondered how Pangea split. Now I have a little,
I'm giving you a little something of everything here because we got lefties.
We got right. He's look, I got an American flag and the controller.
I always love to have a map in my studio to feel situated. Yeah.
So you got two shows. You've done a budget things I said to you right before.
I'm not even gonna use notes.
I try not to really look at my notes when I talk to most guests. Anyway,
I thought I'd just sit down and see what happens.
You kind of just need to be wound up and then, yeah.
Right. Well, you know what, but I tell you, as I get older,
I need to be wound up and let go less. I just listen. It's contentious. Now.
I was more of a, I don't want to use the it's a tired term firebrand,
but I was more willing to engage lock antlers. When I was young,
I don't think people are going to change their minds anymore.
I don't want to be the carnival Barker on some freak show. People were split.
We'll find out where we go, which way at each election in between,
it's going to be contentious. Uh, at age 66.
I don't want to wake up every day and fight with people about stuff.
They're not going to change their mind on anyway. So when I get going,
I like to put on a good show. You know, your, uh, your Spanky and our gang.
Let's put on a show.
I don't need the, I don't need to get going as much anymore.
So you're like an evolved political satirist or.
Something. I just, uh, I used to dig the game.
When you could budge somebody in an angstrom, I didn't need them to come over.
I never thought did you gotta to talk to somebody?
And they were going to desert their core beliefs and come over your way.
But they, at least you could see the mulling. I think Mullings gone.
I could see M's gone. It's just now people know nobody's,
everybody's dug in and I ain't mad. I'm trying over here. I appreciate it.
But like I said, I don't know you're in your forties, right?
I would've probably fought the flop more then,
but I'm telling you why you seem like, uh, just the time we talked beforehand,
you seem like a smart enough, got that somewhere down the road.
I can't see you fighting it into the barn. Seem to be alone. You know,
it was a beautiful family. And the picture out here got a great place.
You're kicking and taking names. Career-wise yeah, you should do it now.
But at some point the harvest is, uh,
you're going to do I'm into getting up and reading, taking a hike,
having a good meal,
appreciating the fact that I married the most beautiful Woody charming girl I
ever met, uh, adoring.
My son's watching some baseball and then reading his life.
Fall out the sleep. Is that a tough thing though? For a comic to have to face?
Not for me.
But do you think for most comics that's like you almost fear that you fear the
okayness cause you won't have the fuel. It's a FINI.
Job. Yeah, I I'm. I was never very, uh,
I don't know if you show businesses some sword from the stone moment where
you're anointed job. I grew up in Pittsburgh and uh, my job, uh,
what I was good at was, uh,
I would think jokes up and then I tried to give those jokes to somebody else to
do. And then I found I didn't have the ego for that.
Once I saw somebody do a joke,
I thought up on the tonight show and Carson laughing.
I thought I'm not built for this. I better become the unlikely conduit,
but I've never thought of myself as the silver surfer convenient.
Yeah. And so, no, I don't, I don't have any moment pangs or anything. Oh,
I wish I was in the fray.
It never was like that when I was in the fray where you always a political
cause I thought I should get that job on SNL. You have to become political.
So you weren't political before I used to be a.
Prop comic. I remember working with the, I, you know,
I was never quite character opion but I met him actual word.
I think that's probably in the dictionary now. That's depressing. I, uh,
I did props when I first started. Cause I thought that visually that way,
but then I remember I couldn't fit the props in the overhead.
I had slight props and then I thought, you know,
I'm not going to wait a half hour at a.
Right. So for some inflatable I could.
Put on my head and say, alas for turning
That on, that started writing jokes. Like I said,
stoled a couple of other comedians,
saw them do them and score with them and thought I've got to be the guy. So, um,
I, like I said, it was very, uh,
I didn't have a whoosh whoosh thing about standup. I remember thinking, okay,
this is a good career.
Kind of a decision. So when you get the weekend updates situation,
the S and L situation, then it's sorta like it was political. What, what,
what year did you start at SNL? Somewhere in the eighties. Somewhere,
somewhere in there.
No, I'm not doing that deliberately. Just, uh, I remember I was, uh,
mainly Hmm.
Nine or something. Cause I'm trying to remember cause you on SNL, that,
that class was like my formative comedy year class. So I was like 12,
13 around then. And I think, I think maybe like 89 or something.
Okay. Well, some people think of themselves as comedic visionaries.
I choose to think of ourself as ushering kids through puberty. We as a yeah.
If you were 12 or yeah, that's all we were,
that was 15 minutes off from jerking off. But you guys did it.
I made it out. Okay.
But I remember I was in Baltimore and I had auditioned for SNL maybe a
month before.
And then I remember, um,
they pick the cast USA today had picture of him.
I wasn't in and I was still in Baltimore and I was so tough at that point,
because on your way up, you have to be tough. I did stand up in New York,
12 years. I was a gladiator. And I remember seeing that picture.
I didn't have a crestfallen thing. I think I came close to that. All right,
keep going. Uh, then I was up doing Letterman and uh,
somebody came into the Letterman dressing room and said, uh, listen,
Lauren Michaels wants to see you on eight or no 17 where his office was.
And I said, geez, I knew something was that.
He's not calling me down to revisit me to tell me why he didn't it to me,
really not getting it.
But I'm thinking maybe I get a shot on it as a comedian or something like Steven
Wright would come on Sam once in a while. So, um, I went down,
I knew it was going to be something good. But then I walked in.
I remember it's one of those moments that stick in your head.
Lauren sits at the end of the thing.
He's got one of those green dome to glasses, uh, lights on his desk, you know,
that gives it that Arthur Conan, Doyle feel.
And he's got the quarter glasses on reading scripts or something.
And I over his shoulders, the empire state building.
And I remember it being like red, white, and blue.
And it was important to July or anything, but he looks up and he goes,
Hey Dennis Miller. I go, Hey Lauren. He says,
how would you like to do a weekend update? And I said, I'd like that a lot.
I said, I'll see you tomorrow around 11. I said, all right, sir,
I walked out and then I remember thinking I'm not a big drinker,
but I remember thinking I'm going to go get four fingers of something Brown on
the rocks and knock this down because this is pivotal. And, uh,
that was magical. I don't want to act like I'm sitting over here, like Putin,
I'm talking about standup. I was kind of step-by-step ImageNow line,
move it six inches fallback for move it for. But when that happened,
I remember thinking, all right, take some mental Polaroids here.
Don't be blahzay about this. Cause that's its own defense mechanism.
This is a big deal. Chevy chased it, this you're going to do it now.
Enjoy it until you either become a success or get whacked.
So I did enjoy it along the way. I took all those moments and you know,
the first time you sit in that seat, yeah. Count your dad. I just thought,
all right, I might go up, but I'm going out on my shield here.
So even though you weren't purely political, they, they pegged you for that.
Where you is. That is that, is that what you wanted? Did you want to do more?
I wanted any hook. I didn't, I'm not a character guy.
I used to try to stay out of the SNL sketches because, uh, you know,
when you're with geniuses, Carly's comedic, genius, love it's uh, the,
the sketch wise, a genius, Phil, the ultimate glue guy. Me,
the only guy I never thought I'd see a guy like Danny and Phil got in the room
with them. And I always thought, wow, this is a serious play.
Mike Myers comes in. So you've got four leads there that could kill the ball.
I'm the fifth guy in a sketch. I'm the bartender saying, here's your Gimlet.
And yet I gotta be there blocking it for three and a half hours.
So I used to go around and say to writers when they wrote me in, I'd say,
I want to be like the DH. I want to pick a rock song.
They swing the weighted bat down the tunnel,
come out and hit the ball for 10 minutes. And by the end you had that, right?
Yeah. It was a groovy job. And I used to,
I probably been in around a dozen sketches over the years and they were ones
where I thought, Oh, this is good. I should stay in this because I want to see,
uh, I want to see this when I get older, uh, it's a wonderful life.
The next chapter, you know, you knew when something was going to be a big hit,
but by and large, I was really happy to have just weekend update.
For more honest and thoughtful conversations about comedy instead of the nonstop
yelling, you get everywhere else, check out our comedy playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist,
they're both right over here and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.